many of you expressed a great interest
and and enjoyment from what's going on
between elon musk and the maga people
and donald trump and there's another
crazy layer to this story which is that
donald trump spent the afternoon
yesterday on truth social also known as
truth central to donald trump attacking
elon musk and this is one of the
funniest
uh
it's sort of like a like a relationship
gone bad they're now estranged lovers of
sorts so let me give you the backstory
on what's going on when elon musk
announced he's going to buy twitter and
he's going to bring back
free speech or what whatever nonsense
elon musk said
the wright and the maga right flocked
back to twitter and they flock to elon
musk as their savior he's going to
return our voice and we're no longer
going to be discriminated against for
being
a transphobic or what you know whatever
they wanted to do
then
elon musk
was even further ingratiated with these
right-wingers when he started saying i
am now although i've never voted for
republicans before i'm going to start
voting for republicans i am now going
i'm still a moderate but i'm going to
start voting for republicans because i
believe they're better than democrats
and what they offer and the maga crowd
absolutely loved it but then
um things went sour and the first thing
that happened is that elon musk said i'm
actually not going to buy twitter and
over the weekend during his anchorage
alaska rally donald trump uh said
elon musk told me that he voted for me
but then later he said i've never voted
for republicans before elon musk
reported responded to that report on
twitter and said not true saying trump
is lying saying i never told donald
trump that i told him that i voted for
him and then
at the very same anchorage
rally donald trump started going after
elon musk in a more significant way
another one of our highest priorities
under a republican congress will be to
stop left-wing censorship and to restore
free speech in america
and go out by the way while i'm here and
sign up now for truth social it's hot as
a pistol and you see that i pull that
one right
leon's i tell you what
elon
elon
is not gonna buy twitter
where did you hear that before
from me
from a fake account she says fake a lot
of them
nah he's got himself a mess you know he
said the other day oh i've never voted
for a republican i said i didn't know
that he told me he voted for me
so he's another [ __ ] artist but he's
not going to be buying it
he's not going to be buying it
although he might later who the hell
knows what's going to happen he's got a
pretty rotten contract i looked at his
contract not a good contract yeah
unclear how trump got a hold of that
contract but anyway so elon musk
responded to that as well and he said
listen this is a quote from elon musk i
don't hate the man but it's time for
trump to hang up his hat and sail into
the sunset democrats should also call
off the attack don't make it so that
trump's only way to survive is to regain
the presidency so musk turning on trump
the maga twitter people going bonkers
and then trump just absolutely erupts
yesterday on truth social spending the
afternoon ranting and raving about elon
musk saying quote when elon musk came to
the white house asking me her for help
on all of his many subsidized projects
whether it's electric cars that don't
drive long enough by the way
i mean you know praise or criticize musk
for whatever you want but the range on
tesla's is at the top of electric
vehicles okay electric cars that don't
drive long enough driverless cars that
crash or rocket ships to nowhere without
which subsidies he'd be worthless and
telling me how he was a big trump fan
and republican
i could have said drop to your knees and
beg and he would have done it
now elon should focus on getting himself
out of the twitter mess because he could
owe 44 billion dollars for something
that's perhaps worthless also lots of
competition for electric cars ps why was
elon allowed to break the 15 million
dollar stock purchase barrier on twitter
without any reporting that is a very
serious breach have fun elon and jack
go to it now funny that trump tags
jack dorsey
but that's jack dorsey's on twitter he's
not on truth social as far as i could
tell look at how quickly elon musk went
from right wing savior to right wing
enemy just because he said i'm not
buying twitter
i never told trump i voted for him and
trump should move on from politics and
he is now the enemy
this is the epitome of how trump works
but it is also
how the maga people work
you're either uniquely good or uniquely
bad you're either the absolute best
person in the world or someone who
should be ostracized and maybe even
imprisoned if donald trump really
doesn't like you and all along whatever
your opinion is of elon musk
elon musk's behavior was his typical
sort of self-centered
um uh what whatever it was i called it
yesterday it's sort of sort of like a
self-centered uh prioritization of his
own interests at the end of the day
and we've seen this with trump before
and we've seen this with the trump
people oh this this person is now bad
he's on some kind of naughty list and it
is absolutely childish it's
extraordinarily pathetic and by the way
for someone who said i'm going to be a
great president because i'm going to
pick the right people to work with
it's incredible how poor trump's
judgment has been selecting all sorts of
people for his staff who he ultimately
has to fire or demand resignations from
and then says they were terrible people
all along they were incompetent they
were given too much of responsibility
well who gave them that responsibility
it was donald trump none of musk's views
have changed whatever they are and
whatever you believe them to be they
haven't changed what's changed is that
donald trump started making specific
claims about things elon musk told him
and musk says i didn't say those things
and now trump ends up like a little kid
uh spending his afternoon on truth
social attacking elon musk stunning
stunning stuff and humiliating
as many of you know i take my snacks
very seriously i avoid excess sugar and
junk food and so when i want something
sweet
i go to our sponsor monk pack monk pack
makes my favorite granola bars and nut
and seed bars if you're doing keto it
works just one gram of sugar or less
only two to three net carbs under 150
calories the flavors are delicious sea
salt dark chocolate that's my favorite
you've got your coconut cocoa chip
you've got your caramel sea salt the
texture the flavors this is a beautiful
granola bar and then you've got monk
packs nut and seed bars which are more
crunchy
if you're craving something like a
crunchy chocolate candy bar monk pack is
the perfect thing to grab instead same
taste same experience none of the carbs
and sugars and calories
get twenty percent off your first order
at monkpack.com using the code pacman at
checkout the link is down below